il bouge aux auditeurs élus d'opposition
de la ville de fort de france et du de
fox a changé faute france vous êtes avec
nous au moment où didier laguerre le
maire de la ville est actuellement à
paris pour assister au comité des
finances locales c'est avec un ordre du
jour le sous financement des
collectivités d'autre mairie justement
on va parler des finances de la ville de
fort de france la chambre régionale des
comptes qui demande au préfet de mettre
son nez dans cette affaire grave ou à
dire vous en tant qu'opposition
aujourd'hui oui alors merci de me poser
cette question il faut savoir que la
ville de faux le fos a voté pour le
budget 2010 8 un budget à hauteur de 2 9
millions est ce que nous remarquons
c'est que d'abord il y a surendettement
de la ville qui se monte à 230 millions
duo ce qui fait que il faudra la ville
150 années pour rembourser
ceci m'a dit moi alors le 12 années on a
présenté sa chance à deux années douze
années sont dans une collectivité de
cette dimension sont exigées la deuxième
chose et c'est la chose la plus
importante sur laquelle vous mettez au
g1 déficit c'est le 50e réussite de plus
de 55 millions d'euros
et ça a été notifiée à la municipalité
dès le 19 décembre 2018 et la
municipalité ne nous ont rien fait c'est
à dire que nous avons eu un conseil
municipal où pratiquement on l'avait
l'impression que les choses étaient
normales et ne voilà-t-il pas que la
chambre régionale des comptes est revenu
à la change et en dix ans les
argumentations du maire ne sont pas
valables oui les argumentation juridique
du maire selon
lesquels il n'y avait pas le temps
nécessaire pour revoir le budget de 2018
n'était pas valable et cette chambre
régionale des comptes demande désormais
au préfet de mettre son nez là dedans et
de régler le budget 2010 8 est ce que
vous estimez vous aujourd'hui à tant qu
élue d'opposition que la ville de fort
de france est sous tutelle
oui nous pouvons le dire parce que
depuis que le prix fait une lecture
pauline inclut le préfet c'est quand
même un organes déconcentrés de l'état
c'est le représentant du gouvernement
ici si il met son nez dans une
collectivité dans le budget d'une
collectivité locale
eh ben c'est une mise sous tutelle c'est
à dire que il faut savoir que la règle
c'est la libre administration des
collectivités locales c'est à dire c'est
ce sont les jeunes qui ont été élus par
le peuple qui doivent posséder au budget
et aux rectifications d'auxi le préfet
est amené à régler le budget de 2018
eh bien nous allons vers une mise sous
tutelle
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé en
guadeloupe on en prendre un petit peu
plus longuement dans le journal de 8
heures puisque le maire de
pointe-à-pitre jacques bangou et sous
une procédure de révocation de la part
du préfet de guadeloupe ont un déficit
de 78 millions d'euros
vous souhaiteriez de ça arrivera ici en
martinique c'est la 2 figurent celles à
dire que je n'y ai n'a souhaité de la
part des organismes d'état ce que nous
aurions préféré c'est une révocation
populaire de l'équipe en place est tenté
de dire que la campagne a commencé et
que cette campagne pour les élections de
l'année prochaine élection municipale ce
à partir à fait la question financière
du budget de la ville de fort de france
sera un des gros arguments mais
absolument parce que depuis que nous
avons été élus en 2014
nous avons nous n'avons cessé de tirer
la sonnette d'alarmé sur laquelle situe
dans l'opposition sur la question
financière et nous avons tout de suite
mis en relief
l'opacité qu'il y avait au niveau des
finances de la ville de fort de france
comment expliquer
que une opposition qui a quand même dix
élus au niveau du conseil municipal soit
écarté de fonction comme et comme le
conseil d'administration du 6 ans mc
c'est à dire que nous ne pouvons pas
regarder dans l'assiette et organismes
ce qui se passe au niveau financier et
je vous dis que le préfet avait saisi la
chambre régionale des comptes
justement si vous la situation
financière du si en mode et la chambre
régionale des comptes
naturellement as a service a du talent
n'est ce pas regarder toute la situation
du budget devant le feu dimanche en
pente et titi vous êtes dans
l'opposition mais franchement qu'est ce
que vous auriez pu faire vous si vous
vous étiez aux manettes
alors d'abord lorsqu'il ya un héritage
quand même
alors c'est vrai que et nous avons déjà
fait l'argument que home et actuel il y
un héritage il dit l'assumé la question
ce n'est pas déployer un vis-à-vis de
son corps parce qu'ils savent il s'agit
bien depuis plusieurs années au niveau
de cette municipalité d'une politique de
clan pour un clan mais ce ce que nous
disons c'est que la vérité des chiffres
ces pauses c'est à dire que même si vous
assumez la politique qui a été menée
parce que il faut savoir qu'au niveau
nous l'appelons le néo ppm au niveau du
néo ppm les deux totems au niveau de la
gestion qu'il bondisse partout
c'est le 6e endettement c'est à dire que
l'endettement ce n'est pas un problème
au contraire ça montre une collectivité
en activité et le déficit non plus c'est
pas une temps c'est quelque chose qu'ils
doivent aller
or aujourd'hui nous constatons que cette
ville est complètement à l'arrêt mais
monsieur charpentier titi il y a une
masse salariale il y à des
investissements qu'il faut faire pour
rendre cette ville attractive
il ya peut-être eu des erreurs de
gestion de la ville de la part des
prédécesseurs peut-être même de l'indu
du maire actuel je vous repose la
question vous qu'auriez-vous fait
aujourd'hui si vous étiez assise sur le
siège de monsieur didier laguerre alors
d'abord nous ne faisons nous ne ferions
pas l'impression d'être surpris par ce
qui arrive c'est à dire que dès notre
arrivée aux commandes de la ville
il serait absolument important de faire
un audit de la situation financière de
la ville
c'est à dire que filiale en boucle a
défendu politique il ya eu il y avait
voudriez qu'ils fassent d'audit par
rapport à ses prédécesseurs et ami
policier vous dire il va avoir le
résultat de toutes les politiques
calamiteuses qui ont été menées c'est à
dire que nous vous me posez la question
aurait en tant qu'opposition c'est à
dire qu' il faudrait absolument faire un
audit de la ville de fort de france
parce que depuis des années renier cette
opacité et par conséquent il faut savoir
où nous mettons les pieds
la deuxième chose peut nous pouvons
espérer c'est que la résorption de ce
déficit se se couvrent sur plusieurs
années plusieurs exercices a fait que la
la ville
et quand je parle de la ville ce n'est
pas l'équipe qui est en place mais parce
que je me soucie très très peu de son
sang ce ce qui est en cause ce sont les
intérêts des fouilles aller car en fin
de compte ce sont les foyalais qui
seront obligés de payer la facture et il
faut savoir qu'au niveau des impôts
pratiquement il y a une possibilité
d'augmenter les impôts info de force
quand nous sommes déjà pratiquement plat
fontenay monsieur l'a dit oui et puis je
voudrais dit également
c'est à dire qu'il faut sortir de
l'immobilisme de la ville il faut donner
un bal à cette ville c'est à dire que
c'est vrai nous sommes ici en martinique
poweo martinique pommier d'ailleurs
était toujours à fort de france mais le
nombre de go d'administration qui ont
laissé faire de fausses vous allez vous
promener dans la ville
le nombre de wii prestigieuse que fort
de france avait et qui sont maintenant
karim en fait je ne dirais pas la bonne
je ne veux pas faire de caricatures
mais il y a et tours le mans division si
on le voit il ya beaucoup de problèmes
de division 1
alors il y à il y a des problèmes
d'indivision mais je pense qu'il y a une
politique forte à mener pour repeupler
le centre-ville parce que ce qui est
assez vrai que la population de la
martinique père et des habitants mais
depuis très longtemps nous avons
remarqué qu'à foi de fausses il y avait
une fuite par rapport à soi ou tous des
impôts ou au 06 se voudra confirmer que
cette question des finances de la ville
de fort de france sera le thème central
de la prochaine campagne étoiles mais
c'est un thème incontournable
c'est à dire qu'il faut expliquer à la
population
quel est le type de politique qui a mené
à cette catastrophe financière parce que
la ville est pris dans un étau la ville
et pris deux côtés par le surendettement
de 230 millions à régler pratiquement
sur 150 aux voiliers ligne les normes
sont gigantesques et puis le déficit de
55 millions d'habitants avec l'irruption
de l'état dans les questions financières
donc là c'est un thème absolument
incontournable de la campagne qui va
s'ouvrir
merci clément charpentier titi élus
d'opposition de la ville de fort de
france élu de force a changé faute
france